auparavant Nicolas Sarkozi avait
sacrifié un grand classique la remontée
des Champs-Élysées en voiture
décapotable pour aller raviver la flamme
sous l'Arc de Triomphe François baudonet
Jean-Marie
lecartier c'est depuis les jardins du
palais présidentiel que Nicolas Sarkozi
rejoint les ChampsÉlysées ce passage est
d'ordinaire réservé aux visiteurs qui
aiment la discrétion mais il est aussi à
deux pas des
Champs comme ses prédécesseurs le
nouveau président de la République
é par la Garde
Républicaine la voiture est un prototype
que jacquesirac n'avait jamais
utilis au pied de l'Arc de Triomphe
Nicolas Sarkozi apparaît tout d'abord
[Musique]
tendu il ravive ensuite la flamme du
soldat
inconnu des gestes traditionnel pour un
président
nouvellementlu mais
Nicolas sarzi semble ne plus écouter le
chef du protocole qui l'accompagne il
s'autorise alors dans la plus grande
bousculade son premier bain de foule de
chef de
l'État je suis venu de Genève pour venir
le voir on vient de Suisse pour le voir
ou vous êtes contente pour le voir très
contente lorsque quelques minutes plus
tard il redescend les ChampsÉlysées
Nicolas Sarkozi semble un autre homme
plus décontracté plus souriant bref un
style à la
Kennedy et c'est peut-être parce qu'il
est le premier président de la
République à ne pas avoir connu de
guerre mondiale que Nicolas Sarkozi
souhaite c'est une première rendre
hommage à georgees Clémenceau celui que
l'on surnommait le Père la Victoire
hommage aussi au général de Gaulle au
pied de sa statue érigée il y a 7 ans à
peine le recueillement passé Nicolas
Sarkozi ne résiste pas à l'appel d'un
nouveau bain de foule à son rythme
etiné en entrant sur les champs éélysées
Nicolas Sarkozi était déjà président de
la République lorsqu'il les quitte il a
endossé les habits de chef de
l'État